seul vis-à-vis les flammes ce qu à la
tenter de se frayer un chemin jusqu'à ce
que cette femme viennent à son secours
malheureusement ce koala a succombé à
ses blessures
au total ils seraient près de 8000 koala
avoir péri en raison des feux de forêt
pour les autorités chaque sauvetage
compte si bien que ces pompiers ont pris
une pause pour aider un groupe de six
koala l'état de la nouvelle galles du
sud qui abrite entre 15000 et 28000
koala aurait perdu le tiers de ces
spécimens puisque le tiers de leur
habitat a été détruit explique un
ministre de l'environnement de
l'australie les autorités travaillent à
la remise en liberté des populations de
koalas rescapés l'animal emblématique
des australiens depuis le déclenchement
des fins 5 millions d'hectares de forêts
ont été décimés en australie soit un peu
plus que la belgique en termes de
superficie et si gabriel proulx radio
canada montréal